hello everyone this game is also from
the european team chess championship
this one was played today this is round
five and uh clear my madero is playing
against the number one rated Czech chess
grandmaster David navara and it's not
like I'm on purpose only choosing the
games were checked in grandmasters lose
it's just it's a very interesting game
which I'm sure you'll agree so Chuck has
the white pieces and he plays d4 we have
d5 c4 and the D captures on c4 the
Queens gambit accepted III Knight to f6
we have visual captures on c4
recapturing the pawn east six now Knight
to f3 c5 my idea of castles a6 preparing
b5 we have Queen to eat to now navara
does play b5 we have Bishop to d3 and C
captures on d4
this is move eight and already a very
interesting move by mami dr if he plays
rook to d1 sacrificing a pawn for not
immediately an attack but definitely for
an for active play and here
Navarre played Bishop to e7 preparing to
castle he doesn't want to go into some
unknown lines but a most interesting
position would arise if for example
Navarro played the D captures on e3 and
for example Bishop to e4 now opening up
a disguise
discovered attack from the roof to the
Queen and also from the bishop to the
rook an a8 but here's the thing he
captures an f2 with check King to f1 not
capturing the pawn to allow Bishop to c5
would check Queen captures and d1 now
sacrificing the Queen the Queen captures
on d1 and Knight captures on e4 and here
navara would have a rook and the bishop
for a queen but this here is a beautiful
pawn on f2 and this King is pretty much
stuck on f1 with correct play this could
go either way
for example Queen c2 attacking the
knight Bishop to b7 defending and black
is already
very nicely developed in he's ready to
bring all of his pieces into the game so
this would probably result in a very
interesting game but ok Navarre decided
not to go for this
I have to rook to d1 he played Bishop to
e7 we had a 4 now breaking up that a 6/8
b5 pawn chain B captures on a 4 and we
have rook captures on a 4 D captures on
e3 now Navarra Navarra Avella is the
position correctly and decides that he
does have time to capture the pawn we
have Bishop captures on e3 and Knight B
to d7 Knight to c3 Navarre castles and
Bishop to g5 and for the price of one
pawn mama tiara now has a very nicely
developed pieces this rockin a4 is
covering the entire fourth rank it can
go to f4h for g4 if if this night ever
moves so quite an active piece this
Bishop light-square bishop is nicely
eyeing that h7 squared so you know
pretty much an equal position we have
Bishop to b7 rook to d4 now pinning the
night and well this is already a move
that comes with a trick if for example
some developmental move was played like
rook to c8 then Bishop captures an f6
and after Bishop captures rook captures
on d7 you can't capture the rook if you
capture it you get Bishop captures on h7
would check of course King captures and
rook captures Queen so this would be
quite unfortunate for navara so after
rook to d4 Navarre of course saw this he
played Bishop captures on f3 Queen
captures on f3 and now as the queen is
on f3 he plays Knight to e5 on pinning
his Knight now would a temple on the
White Queen on f3
shock is down upon so of course he
doesn't want to trade Queens he plays
Queen to III and Queen to b8 and getting
the Queen out of the way also kinda with
a temple on this b2 pawn bishop to f4
now with a double attack on the night
and also pinning it's the knight cannot
move Knight eg4 now
the Night Moves nevertheless and now
also would attempt on the Queen again of
our offers an exchange of queens but
again
Medea of declines this Queen to eat too
we have a five now with an attack on the
rook and the bishop in Bishop to g3 the
rock cannot be captured the bishop is
still painting this pawn we have aged
five and night the d5 and here the
fireworks begin probably the best idea
here would be to capture this night with
night captor Sun d5 simply because you
want to free this f6 Square for your g4
night but here Navarre played rook to e8
and this gives mama D out of a bit too
much mommy never plays h3 now attacking
this night and this is the problem the
night it doesn't really have anywhere to
go
it can go to h6 but if you play Knight
to h6 you get Bishop captures on e5 now
attacking the Queen and well the best
defense will be something like Bishop to
f8 now if better characters Queen rook
captures Queen honey - but this is also
given up the exchange so why doesn't
even have to go for this he can he can
capture the Queen and then after rook
captures capture the rook but he can
simply play rook to e4 and continue this
game having a better position
but after h3 Navarre decided not to go
for this as this would well definitely
losing the game he tried h4 and here
shark played and Knight captures on f6
we have Bishop captures on f6 and now
Queen to e4 and already this comes well
of course not really relevant that the
queen is attacking the knight the night
was already attacked by the H born but
he's threatening Queen to h7 with check
infiltrating the back rank we have g6
stopping this and now grabbing the night
for example Queen Catherine g4 and
allowing H captors and g3
white attack is pretty much over here
it's it's well again an equal game but
probably what a better
for black so after g6 mama D ro finds
another way to continue the attack he
plays Bishop to c4 and now the bishop is
spinning the f7 pawn the threat is Queen
captures on g6 would check so noir stops
this King to g7 and we have roped the b7
and the rook is now occupying the
seventh rank this is very very good for
my media roof we have rook to e7 and our
better characters on h4
Bishop captures on h4 and Queen captures
on g4 would an attack on the bishop on
h4 and also adding protection to the
rook on d7 here we have Bishop to f6 and
well here Mahmud I replayed rook 7 to d6
but unfortunately he missed an
insta-kill with Bishop captures on f7
this would have been devastating for
Navarra
if King captures an f7 then rook 1 to d6
and whatever black plays he is simply
lost for example if he plays rook to a7
Queen to e6 with check the rook cannot
capture the Queen as it's pinned and
after King to f8 Queen captures Bishop
King to g8 now Queen captures rook and
after rook at 477 and rocky after 77
there is no defense against checkmate on
the seventh rank
so after this rook to d6 move he would
probably have to play something like
Queen to f8 but it doesn't really matter
after rook captures and Queen captures
you get a rook to d7 and now black loses
the Queen this is winning for white and
the other thing is if you play Bishop
captures on e7 you get Queen to g6
checkmate so it would definitely be
faster if if shock saw this Bishop
captures on f7 idea but again I didn't
watch this game live I don't know if if
either player was in time trouble or
anything so ok his idea was you was also
I mean was also a great move
he played rock deep d6 rook 736 and we
have rocked the c7
Queen to f3 now would an attack on the
bishop on f6
Bishop to h4 and now rook the d7 and
here this is simply too much white is
attacking the f7 pawn with the bishop
with the Queen with the rook you can't
really defend it
the pawn cannot can't really move it's
been from the rook the rook and c7 is
attacked so we definitely do have to
exchange it first and after rook
captures and rook captures which was
played there's really nothing to do here
Navarro tried the Queen to b4 he allowed
the Queen captures on f7 because there's
really nothing else to do but this leads
to an inevitable checkmate Queen
characters on f7 was played King to h6
now Queen to h7 would check King to g5
here f4 was played doesn't really matter
if you capture the point you get to R up
to d5 this also leads checkmate
King to f5 was played and now Queen to
f7 with check King to e4 and now Queen
captures on g6 and in this position
David navara resigned the game he didn't
want to allow mama dr of to continue the
King hunt unfortunately but whatever
black plays here it's checkmate if he
goes the e3 rub the d3 check King
Carter's on f4 and out rook to f3 this
is checkmate and after Queen Queen to g6
check please King after Sun f4 you get
Queen to g4 with check King to e3 and
rook to e3
checkmate so although the King hunt
wasn't finished it's also I mean it's a
quite a nice King hunt by chakra and
mamedyarov so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it like I said it's not on
purpose that in both of my today's
videos check the grandmasters lost I
will rectify this very soon so yeah I do
hope you enjoyed this as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
all for watching and I will see you soon